[Musique]
ces brebis sont des manèges tête noire
une race locale bien adapté à la
transhumance
allez c'est pourtant la montée n'est pas
si simple
les espaces en israël au nord du pays
donc un photographe qui en fait pilote
des drones et à côté de son activité à
des projets personnels de photos et il
s'est donc installé dans cette ferme au
nord du pays pour capturer ces
mouvements de moutons certaines femelles
ont quant à elle trouvé un tout autre
usage aux pierres qu'elle les utilise
pour attirer l'attention des mâles de
manière percutante
malgré les apparences ces attaques ne
sont pas un signe d'agressivité mais
bien une habile forme de séduction des
mégots un bout de papier du plastique
les traces d'incivilité jonchent les
rues de cette petite ville touristique
mais désormais gare à ceux qui jetteront
leurs déchets sur la voie publique
lamanda obernai est très salée une des
fins scientifiques dans le cadre
contrôlé on voit une personne en train
de faire ce geste là et de partir et
viendra 1000 euros ça fait cher la can
est certaine elles sont plus sensibles
de la mamelle du cousu près pareil que
les autres elles vont elles vont avoir
tendance à taper ou à te signaler que ça
leur fait un peu mal d'autres signalent
si tu vas trouver trop fort de petites
choses comme ça pour ce dépôt sauvage
pas de flagrant délit mais il suffit de
fouiller un peu pour trouver le
responsable c'est une enveloppe une
facture des éléments qui me tue qui nous
donne le nom de la personne les
policiers peuvent aussi s'appuyer sur le
système de vidéosurveillance de la ville
je reçois des demandes du monde entier
de chercheur en neurologie qui veulent
appliquer des algorithmes pour
comprendre les déplacements des moutons
peut-être pour étudier les mouvements de
foule je ne sais pas trop j'espère que
tout ça servira à créer quelque chose de
bénéfique à l'humanité on le sait pas
forcément parce qu'on regarde la
publicité on dit que c'est la nôtre et
ben non que l'on habite vire qui l'aviez
ou en provence
on va vous avez qui était bizarre on va
avoir des marques qui vont être
différentes en fonction de la
géolocalisation du téléspectateur
ce chat est déjà une star avec des
heures d'apparition publié sur internet
entre deux siestes il devrait même
bientôt pouvoir parler au public des
apparitions spectaculaire entrecoupée de
publicité diffusée juste à la sortie de
la guerre la plus fréquentée du monde
qu'ils espèrent le faire d'ici la fin de
l'année serre que vous allez avoir un
journal télévisé qui va être en
adéquation avec vos goûts avec vos
habitudes avec la durée par exemple
avoir des journaux télé est plus court
pour certains plus long pour d'autres et
puis avec surtout votre thème de
prédilection qui vont il est rare qu'ils
aient différemment dans le cadre de
l'information foot idées cadeaux pour
convaincre de se
faire vacciner à argenteuil la réponse
est oui
la mairie cible les jeunes avec ce clip
elle organise un jeu concours dans la
rue ils découvrent l'initiative et le
premier prix un week end en europe
voilà maintenant j'hésite alors là je ne
sais pas si je vais faire emmerder
on peut voir ça comme ça peut-être qu'il
faut donner des bons d'achat de 50 euros
200 euros c'est une manière de s'en
sortir et s'assemblent et ça ne s'est
pas que ça semble ça marche
aux états unis ça marche les états unis
précurseur de cette vague d'incitations
qui gagne maintenant le monde entier les
américains ont convaincu à grands coups
de donuts de bière et même de joints de
marijuana
sans oublier ce chèque d'un million de
dollars et j'ai rapidement compris que
pour les gens du cru il n'y avait pas
matière à rire je suis en train d'enfer
parisien
personnellement mon héros de l'année ce
n'est pas une ode musk qui m'annonce que
la pelouse sera verte sur mars
moi ça a été charles henry 22 ans qui me
livrer mes soucis à 22 heures ce sont
celles et ceux que je ne connais pas
parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui que les
promesses de loeb ne peuvent jamais être
tenu
parce que la grandeur d'une vie on a
choisi pas aujourd'hui c'est l'élection
de l'image dorna élu en 2000 il ya plus
rien en 2012 on a élu un président parce
qu'il avait perdu 20 kilos oui 2010 a
beaucoup aidé vous rappelle qu'avant
2012 on disait que françois hollande
n'est pas ouverte dans ce quartier qu'il
avait sa limousine
j'ai compris que c'était charles henry
qui vous livrer vos sushis à 22h on dit
que je voulais savoir où est ce que vous
habitez on a un mot ici qui s'appelle
méfie mais même si ça veut dire
attention donc
attention on n'est pas forcément des
méchants mais par contre faut pas
vraiment venir nous chercher quoi fait
très très grave ou gueule c'est simple
c'est un peu ça le message à l'humour
parfois change de camp
mais les clichés sont toujours jeunes
dans le même camp parce que figurez-vous
que j'habite à marseille
alors c'est vrai mais là bas c'est ça
justement peut-être qu'à paris les
karimi sont dans la rue à marseille ils
sont à l'université et pas franchement
j'adore les hommes politiques mais en
fait je pourrais parler si je parlais
c'est comme si je vais pas utiliser des
explosions vous en avez rien à faire de
ce que je vous ai dit mais rien à faire
je vous pose une question mais vous en
avez absolument rien à faire vous partez
sur un autre truc je vous dis quelque
chose de simple pourquoi vous n'arrivez
pas à désigner votre candidat c'est ça
ma question
le monde est dirigé par les gangsters
agent orange tonga au brésil et poutine
sont des gangsters ils font absolument
pouces qui ne jouent ils n'ont ni moral
ni scrupules ce couple c'est cela le
monde dans lequel nous vivons et nous
devons nous dresser contre des gangsters
comme eux games rectal lavage adore il
est bien est horrible il est super bien
fait on a retrouvé xavier dupont de
ligonnès dans les tribunes sa mue cet
internaute dix ans de cavale pour
retrouver le fugitif dans les gradins
d'un match de l'euro comment un autre
c'est vrai qu'il y a un petit air de
ressemblance entre l'homme recherché
pour le meurtre de sa famille à nantes
et se supporters espagnols qui n'avait
rien demandé et se retrouve baptisé pour
l'occasion
javier del ponte des ligonnès
[Musique]
à voir
c'est dans le coeur
hélas
un petit
le caire 7 panique ligne
bien sûr il n'y a qu'une façon de gérer
une telle déception